because it's not and this is something
I'm big on on entrepreneurship roads
like health and wellness dude because
it's like Tristan just said bro if you
ain't alive you [ __ ] up what can I
actually eat because bro my diet is
terrible bro like I do every single day
another thing is though you ask these
questions I feel like you already know
the basic answers you eat McDonald's
every day the specifics without covering
the basics you know what I mean it's
like when people care about Fitness
what's the exact correct technique to
lift this and lift that
people who don't train at all just go
running and do some Bush everyone knows
like the answers step one stop eating
McDonald's every day that that once you
do that worry more about the exact
specifics of what you're eating what I
would say it's a good point what I would
say something's really good is always
being conscientious of what you eat at
all times in my life I have some sort of
dietary restriction right so I diet I
limit some sort of thing right now I I
limit high fructose corn syrup like
processed sugars I don't do any of that
garbage I don't think caffeine so I
limit my my diet why so every time I eat
I'm unconscious Bro think about the most
basic common things that everybody has
eating
sleeping exercising the most basic
elements when was the last time throw
that you were like I feel hungry I'm not
gonna eat I'm gonna diet I'm gonna fast
on a plane
I can move let me tell you this one bro
what if what you're experiencing is an
actual hunger what if what you're
experiencing is addiction holy [ __ ]
you're right because you're training
your brain bro like your body My
Lifestyle I'm always like oh I'm about
I'm not really home to a cup so okay so
that's that's an excuse excuse mentality
I'm always talking about people will use
any excuse I'm gonna go on a diet you
know after after my vacation or after I
break New Years almost I knew your
boyfriend because he likes to eat out or
on this and that you can get healthy
food everywhere there was not there is
never a time in any airport in any
convenience store you can eat healthy
and we eat really healthy here in this
house and we eat really delicious food
yeah especially with my new dietitian
I've learned that you can also just like
pack food and bring it with you like
when I went to my friend's College last
week I brought eggs meat and milk with
me yeah maybe when you feel like I'm
gonna go to McDonald's or I'm gonna go
to Taco Bell maybe it's not that you're
hungry maybe
what if the food is designed
specifically to make you an addict
and that is perfect example
Coca-Cola is Coke would you say it's
sweet or is it salty sweet perfect guess
how much sodium is in Coca-Cola a lot
why you why because they're the only not
only that why what does salt do it makes
you thirsty it dehydrates you and makes
you drink more
they purposely put a lunch salt sodium
in it could get there so you drink more
and then you put sugar to cover it up
and also another salt actually makes you
um taste the sugar more
believe it really yes so there's salt in
so all the reasons he said and then
there's salts in a McDonald's milkshake
has a [ __ ] ton of salt in it too that's
crazy the starving I saw something that
I saw a video today I didn't like fact
check it or anything but uh not
McDonald's Doritos puts 30 million
dollars a year into making sure that
their chip as addictive as possible
so with like the comedy crunches your
mouth does the way the powders is on
your um
how the powder tastes that's so
disgusting is that crazy it's disgusting
and it's all chemicals yeah and the way
the powder is like designed is so when
you're done it makes you salivate is
that the right word and then when you're
salivating it tricks your brain into
wanting more of that thing really isn't
that fascinating
I appreciate their Ingenuity but I also
find it disgusting that we fall for it
and that we then can't figure out we're
all too stupid to then figure out why
does everybody have cancer and diabetes
and why can't we think straight I wonder
why you're extremely true this guy
that's why this guy can get back into
shape for us because this guy naturally
lives in a state where he's doing
intermittent fasting yeah every day
three and a half thousand calories
single meal
meal yeah that's better all the time
that's what I do afternoon not before so
I was going to sleep a bit hungry you
know I don't have breakfast in the
morning
at least yeah I don't even realize I do
it yeah so I should avoid breakfast
avoid breakfast yeah let me tell you
about so let me tell you about the
breakfast diet let me tell you about the
breakfast diet have you heard of a guy
called Edward Bernay no all of you so
Edward Bernay is known as the father of
propaganda well I think it was uh when
breakfast wasn't really popular the meat
industry came to Edward Renee who's
known as the father of propaganda
pushing propaganda campaigns and said we
need to push more sales of bacon more
sales of meat can we figure out how to
introduce uh Meats into the breakfast
diet so they built an entire marketing
campaign behind breakfast being the most
important meal of the day it's
skyrocketed sausage sales bacon sales
Ham sales bro breakfast wasn't a thing
they made it a thing money bro isn't
that crazy though that's something you
think is like so fundamentally basic
like breakfast was was put there like
that for a reason so you spend more
money that's the matrix it's wise I need
to look into that because it just sounds
it sounds like BS but everything is BS
so I'll be us so why wouldn't that be
true it's just so crazy that somebody
would create breakfast but when I talked
to I've heard think about the market
though I've heard similar things like
like uh engagement rings engagement
rings weren't a thing yeah they needed
to sell more diamonds and they created a
marketing campaign and they had movie
stars they getting engagement rings big
fancy engagement rings and then regular
people started doing it and now it's uh
you have to save however many months
salary to buy a stupid ring for a girl
when you get a divorce anyway that's
crazy I didn't know that where'd you
find that out not for a long time I read
it somewhere I don't even know the
research mom collectible the founder of
Netflix and what is Netflix bro it's a
propaganda machines bro propaganda
machines bro I'm telling you bro The
Matrix is so [ __ ] deep you got to
start like
reassessing everything and there's a
really good verse in the Bible that says
it's crazy because even like the
conspiracy things they have on Netflix
where they're talking about like 11 9
and stuff they don't even mention like
the three towers that there's three
towers that fell in New York City
there's no footage of a plane hitting
the Pentagon like that stuff's just not
even included in those it's like
controlled propaganda they want you to
think so even though you think you're
getting ahead and learning more
information you're really not it's all
controlled not crazy it's amazing that
they can pull it off it's fascinating
such an interesting time to be alive
yeah while the while the curtain is
being pulled back while people like
Epstein are being uh are suiciding
themselves it's pretty convenient it's
[ __ ] it's pretty convenient that um
that Kanye West is a hundred times more
hated than Jeffrey Epstein ever was yeah
and it's pretty convenient and his
girlfriend is in jail Jeffrey Epstein's
girlfriend is in jail and they haven't
prosecuted or tried to prosecute one
single customer of his who raped young
girls so convenient you have to be able
to put away things to become the next
guy bro you got to become the next level
to get to the next level ground you got
to put away the [ __ ] Foods you're
stronger than that g if you can't
control what you put in your in your
body then what can you actually control
so when I'm hungry what do I do
you you you you ask yourself why am I
you ask yourself do I need a meat no
it's okay
a good thing for a lot of you people
trying to lose weight is if you don't
feel like eating a full plate of eggs it
means you're not actually hungry you
just want to eat something if you're not
in the mood eat a plate of eggs then
you're not truly hungry I saw that and I
was like that's pretty facts that's
pretty good yeah and sometimes if I if I
want to eat something I'll say am I in
the mood for something salty sweet
crunchy creamy and like once I identify
like what I'm in the mood for then I can
fill in the healthy am I really hungry
but the healthy thing like I'll eat in
the mood for something sweet and crunchy
sweet crunchy I can have candy or I can
have an apple yeah nuts or something I'd
have the apple with some peanut butter
and I'm and I did all right
it's [ __ ] simple and easy and people
over complicate and make excuses for
everything that's wrong in their lives
what do you give him one out of ten from
the little bit you saw him I liked
listening to them yeah it seems like an
all right fella all right thank you guys
so much for watching make sure to join
the Discord in my bio you can put videos
us to react there and everything yeah
[Music]
[Music]